(audience cheering)
- I know, I know.
She has that effect on everyone.
No, I have to say, "Puss in Boots,"
this movie y'all, it was
just nominated for an Oscar
but it's literally played in my house
more than any other movie right now.
My kids are obsessed with it.
Do you get this everywhere you go now?
- Yes.
I mean, I didn't know I was going to be
the most famous for becoming a cat.
- I know.
You're not the most famous for that,
but for my six year old son, maybe.
- Yeah, Yeah?
- Yes, yes.
- Yes, his soft paws.
- If he heard your voice he'd freak out.
Soft paws, I know, he does
the dance, everything,
I swear to you he watches it all the time.
- It was such a surprise
because we did it 10 years ago.
- Oh my gosh, are you serious?
- Yeah, this is the sequel,
and we thought it was not gonna happen.
Thank God that cats don't get wrinkles.
(Kelly chuckles)
(audience laughing)
- So wait, are there any
animals that you're afraid of?
- Yeah, I have actually a phobia.
- Oh, like a which-
- Yeah.
I'm always called to be the
collector of the animals
like, "there's a spider,
there's a tarantula!"
Okay, calm down. I pick them
up, I bring them outside.
- Yeah, me too.
- But snakes?
I don't care if its a
scorpion, I'm not afraid.
But snakes, I have a phobia.
- Yeah. So tell me-
(audience laughs and cheers)
Because, I specifically
remember as a child going,
first of all, how many
milk ads do I need to read
and drink milk to get to look like that?
You know like, those
ads when you're a kid?
And secondly, like, how
did you handle that?
That's a python, is it?
- I can't think because
I'm still going around
the fact that you said as a kid.
- Oh!
(audience laughing)
Yeah, but that's because
we look the same age.
Because you found the fountain of youth.
(audience laughing)
- Well, you know, I had to go on trance.
Because, if I was not on trance,
if you look at my eyes, I look a little.
- No one was looking at your eyes.
(audience laughing)
- That's the thing, if you
really stared in my eyes.
- [Kelly] If you really,
you have to focus on that.
(audience laughing)
- [Salma] Yes, yes.
- Yeah, I remember this as a kid.
I mean, even Britney Spears ended up
doing that thing, with the python thing.
Yeah it was just such a pop culture thing.
- But they didn't have
to go on trance like me.
And the thing is that you cannot-
- Did you tell them that you like,
did you tell them that you
were terrified of snakes?
- Yeah.
- Oh, and you just, yeah.
- Oh yeah. Robert Rodriguez said,
"well, Madonna wants your part,
if you cannot dance with
the snake, I call Madonna".
And I'm like, Madonna doesn't
want my little part, okay?
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So don't try to-
- They tried to manipulate you.
- Yes, but I did it, I was proud to.
Because when you are acting
you have to become someone else.
- Did that help? That's probably-
- Yes, absolutely. That's
how you do everything.
But I was very proud that
I was freed of my phobia.
I didn't have to give her
my phobia, she got to be,
and also you girls are going to like this,
I study a lot about
the meaning of a snake.
- Yeah.
- And it represents your inner power.
So when I was going on trance,
it was about dancing with my inner power.
Like having a dance with my inner power.
And I gotta say girls, when you are sad,
or you feel like you have no strength,
close the door, put some music.
- [Kelly] This is what I do.
- And dance when nobody's watching,
or until you get chills.
(audience applauding)
- But it does, it makes
me feel so good to dance.
I love movement.
- Yeah, it gives you power.
- And when I close my eyes,
I picture I look like you.
(audience laughing)
Valentine's is a few days away.
I know this is a big
holiday for you, right?
- Yes, in my country it is the day
of the love and of friendships.
So what a beautiful day, you know?
And in my house is pretty big because
it's an anniversary that
I have with my husband
and it's also my daughter's Saint Day.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- [Salma] Yes, so it's a big day.
- So wait, you once got a big
surprise on Valentine's Day.
- Yes.
- What was it?
- So I was engaged for a long time
but every time it was getting
close I would chicken out.
- Oh why?
- Like three, four times.
Look, I didn't get married until I was 41.
So I always had a phobia
for the marriage thing.
- Yeah, I understand.
- And so, I was kind of famous for it.
(audience laughing)
So anyway, my husband
flew my parents secretly
and on Valentine's Day,
they took me to the court,
like on an intervention.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Like, " I don't like this
dress, I have to get a switch."
And they said sign, they spoke in French,
I don't know what they were saying.
I was looking at (mumbling) and I did it.
And that's my first wedding.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
The first wedding on Valentine's Day.
(audience applauding)
Do you know I married him four times?
- What?
- I've married François four times.
- [Kelly] But what do you mean?
- Never been divorced.
Because then after I was
like ah, and I said okay,
I kind of like it that I'm married now.
(audience laughing)
I want a party.
And so we made a huge party.
(audience applauding)
But I didn't like the cake.
(Kelly laughing)
I was waking in my honeymoon,
"why did I take that cake?
It looked like from out of space.
I just want a normal wedding cake!"
And so we went on a vacation,
and then I did a surprise wedding for him.
- Yeah.
- With a nice proper wedding
cake, you know? And then-
- Why the fourth one?
- Because recently we went to
the same place with the kids,
because the third one was just with the,
we were the whole family
went to the same place.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then they all surprised
me with the same thing,
but reversed, now he
surprised me with that.
- Oh, that's nice.
- The cake was okay.
(audience laughing)
- I will say- (laughing)
- But I'm not a control freak.
- It's actually not fair
how unbelievably talented,
hot and funny you are.
(laughing) It's not fair. Oh my God.
So wait, let's talk about
"Magic Mike's Last Dance."
So what's the movie about?
(audience cheering)
I mean, I think we have a clue,
but who do you play in the movie?
- My name is Maxandra and Maxandra
has kind of lost a little bit her way,
because everybody kind
of underestimates her
and undermines her, like
her friends, her family.
And she's got a lot of
potential but, you know,
she's getting to a certain age
and never did something in her
life that was like her mark.
And on top of it, the
husband cheats on her,
and she's in the middle of a divorce.
- Hmm.
- And then, this guy comes along
and gives her a dance that
says, just like reminds her.
- Yeah.
- Of who she was and what she wanted.
So they go on an adventure.
(audience cheering)
- I wanna be reminded of who I am.
Is that how you get
reminded of who you are?
- I highly recommend it.
- I think a lot of people
would love to find
themselves in that capacity.
(audience laughing)
- So we decide to put a show in a theater
that belongs to me in London,
and we are going to do
something crazy and different.
- That's like the greatest
tease for the movie.
I love that, it's like a fresh
start too and empowering.
- Yeah, it is empowering. That's
the thing about the movie.
It's funny, it's really fun.
It's sexy, I'm not gonna lie.
(audience cheering)
But I mean.
- That is an understatement.
- Except for Channing, he is not sexy.
But the rest of the movie, its okay.
And then on top of it, it's
really empowering for women.
- Yeah, I already knew you could dance,
but yeah it's incredible. Was that fun?
Was that part of the job for this role?
- Yeah, I mean, it was like
going to the office every day.
There were 12 stripers, you know.
(audience laughing and cheering)
Every day, dancing there.
I mean, the thing is that I became kind of
close to them because
they're not even strippers,
they're like really good dancers,
like amazing dancers that
were playing strippers.
But anyway, the dance,
I didn't have to do any of that
because for once I was not stripping,
It was the men who was stripping.
- Which is nice.
That's why these movies are so
amazing and popular as well.
- However, I did learn
that for this dance,
because it's so technical,
do have to learn some moves
and if you make a mistake, you know,
you can poke him in the
eye with your stiletto
or like, in one of the rehearsals,
I had to put my legs
in a position and hard.
And I'm not like the
most, like hard person.
Like I don't work out that much.
I don't have a lot of muscle.
And so he dropped me.
- He dropped you?
- Yeah, I was going down.
I was upside down on top
of, I was going down.
So to grab me, he grabbed onto my pants
and then my pants were about to come off.
So me, instead of put
my hands on the floor
I was grabbing onto to life and moving,
and he's like, "don't move,
put your hands on the floor".
- Break your neck?
- And he's like holding me.
Finally, somebody came and took me away
and I'm still holding till the end.
(audience laughing)
Till the end, I was holding onto my pants.
I'm on the ground, I'm
still holding onto my pants.
So it is technical.
You have to learn, you know,
you have to rehearse and learn.
But the audience that have seen it,
seem extremely happy with the dance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- So I really recommend
that you go watch the movie.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)